i want to talk about your character
april and parks and recreation you've
been i think it'd be
fun to play kind of a mean character i
think that'd be kind of a nice thing to
do yes it's very fun it'd be fun to do
but what's what happens when you
encounter fans do fans expect you to be
mean a lot of people that recognize me
kind of back away
they don't come towards me they don't
approach they recoil yeah i think
because i play i play characters that
are mean
i was in new orleans recently and a
couple i was standing somewhere
on the street and a couple
like came up from behind me and they
were like you're her you're her say
something mean and i went leave me alone
and then they started laughing yeah and
they didn't go away and they didn't go
away because you're giving them what
they want yeah and they just kept
laughing and they were like do it again
and i was like leave me the [ __ ] alone
parks and rec you guys wrapped it up it
must have been very tough saying goodbye
to the cast yeah i mean i feel like it's
been said to death at this point but we
were all really close and uh
you know everyone got each other gifts
and stuff and um uh you know aubrey
plaza and are are very close we've known
each other before the show and um became
really good friends on the show and she
gave me this very nice gift and i wanted
to tell you guys about this gift so she
gave me this gift this is really her
this is a real thing she gave me um she
wrote me this nice note uh
and it said uh aziz no words can
describe how much i care about you but a
pack of my blood and a shard of my hair
i give you a spell for when we're apart
put me somewhere safe and always keep me
in your heart love aubrey and she gave
me this and i was like oh my god
yeah that's pretty awesome aubry gave
you this is this is her blood and her
hair her blood and her hair i was like
this is the greatest sweetest gift like
i was like this is so
this is so like beautiful and it's like
such an aubrey gift and i loved it right
yeah so cut to this weekend i saw her
and uh and and we were hanging out and
uh somehow this gift came up and my
girlfriend was just like well aubry like
that's not really your blood right and
she's like no
and i was like what that's not your
blood what is it and i was like well i
don't know it's just like a jelly or
something and then
i was like what's the hair she's like
that's not my hair i was like so what
what is this thing you just gave me
trash like that's what this is trash in
a bottle you've been carrying that
around i've been keeping it in my heart
i get
so much incredible fan art mainly ron
swanson
and they have you uh your character
conan o'brien and my character ron
swanson both have a pretty similar
hairdo which in my case we referred to
as the full douche
i don't know what they call it around
here now we call it the full douche now
that you
you've just christened it that here's
here's a drawing someone did i don't
know how you feel about this one
wow it's
eerily good
and disturbing at the same time
what's the eyes are incredible on that
by the way it's really it's really good
i get a lot of uh
a lot of art that
seems to be misshapen at the outset
but then as you settle into it you
realize it's actually quite it's a
photograph
you're talking with rashida jones not
long ago a beautiful wife your beautiful
wife uh lovely co-star rashida jones and
she showed her high school yearbook
photo
and um it was it was just such a great
way to sort of get an insight into what
someone was like back in the day and so
is it though yes
yes it is all right yes it is so i have
a feeling you're gonna show mine we have
one uh that we found we found your and i
thought maybe you could just tell us a
little bit
yeah every day i would walk into school
and i would just be like you're welcome
fellas
you can tell you look at that hello and
i'm the lead singer for the go-go's oh
god i wish i wish quite a storm that
morning
i drove all the way there with the
windows down getting my picture taken
and you're you're still close is that
right you and nick hofferman we are
close you know um we're very close i
mean
we're but i there's something that's
happened that's sort of i feel like
tearing us apart
which is sad um
for a long time
nick adam and i would have this pact
that if we had a really exceptional poop
we would take a picture of it and send
it to one another
you know and and recently maybe a year
ago so
this was something that three of you
yeah yeah i know this is the three of
you would do this
as as a way to bond like a share
experience just right just right yes you
would you'd look at a poop and think
that's an offerman i'm sending that to
nick
i think it started when i miraculously
pooped in an n shape one time
and then i sent it and i sent it to nick
and i said hey
it was on nick's birthday i said
you guys have the same birthday
and then uh
i hate to get on this topic but uh your
parks and recreation pal chris pratt was
here recently and he shared with us
something that you
he and nick offerman do right
um do you know where i'm going with this
yeah i'm sorry okay
it's a thing the three of you do you've
been doing it for a while yeah and it's
um
it's one of the odder things i've ever
heard of why don't you tell us what
that's all about and what it is i'd love
to conan um
it's you know it's just a thing that i
don't know i i would imagine offerman
started it where the three of us every
once in a while not every day not every
week not even every month just every
once in a while uh we'll send each other
a photo of a particularly memorable
uh
movement we've had
right
is that is that yeah yeah bowel movement
is that is that landing
that's good right
that's what we do yeah
if you do it i i just heard about it but
if you guys have a particularly uh
prodigious or healthy one you take a
picture of it and you share it with each
other well it's disgusting but you know
the uh and and it's not it's we're not
like tied to it's it's a very
non-committal thing but but yeah every
once in a while like just recently i
think i got one from nick and it said
happy president's day
and i think i think at one point
i may have sent one and just said hey
how about those oscar noms
now it makes sense to me there you go
now it makes sense to me parks and
recreation one of the funniest shows on
television you guys are doing a great
job thank you so you must be thrilled
about that you're having a good time
thank you
i am um
i love it everybody's funny and fun and
it almost feels like you're not working
and i really think at the end of the day
they just want to try to figure out how
they can humiliate me on a daily basis
it doesn't no just as a casual as as a
viewer i
i do notice that it almost seems like
they're sitting around thinking what can
we get rob lowe to do
when will he say no i
i've done horrific air banjo playing i i
i just this week sang the worst version
of take me out to the ball game right
anyone's ever seen and of course i've
done some serious white man dancing yeah
yeah
and that was they didn't even ask you to
do that that was just you trying to be
good yeah
the the uh and then you did something
that went viral uh i remember what it
was but it was uh it was like a huge it
was this very humiliating moment where
they just it and it suddenly it was
everywhere on the computer yeah it was
me looking in the mirror at myself and
telling myself to stop pooping yeah yeah
because you know i need to be reminded
of that on a daily basis
other people look in the mirror and say
you can do it or go get them that's your
mantra every day it works for me conan
all right i'm happy for you i'm just
curious do you like award shows like
that's got to be i don't know if that's
something that that you enjoy is that
something that you look forward to oh i
love them i live for them i uh i've been
watching the emmys and oscars since i
was little i cry at every single award
every single you don't i do oh really
like the technical awards you're crying
well i don't go to those oh okay
i know but every time i watch i cry
every time um i even cried the la the
emmys that i was at because ty burrell
won he's a friend of mine and i was
talking about his dad oh my god
you know the ugly
yeah i do it seems like you guys are in
sync with each other comedically
probably off camera as well as on yeah
it's really a dream job and sometimes i
feel guilty because we like each other
so much um and yeah we often we like
hang out together we have dinner
together we drink together we vacation
together
together we have yeah we have me and and
amy and aubry we try to do like a girls
you know aubrey plaza you guys and what
do you do you get together and you just
hang out hang out we drink a couple
drinks you know
night life no we usually sit in the bed
all three of us and watch tv together
the three of you get together and drink
and hang out in bed
amy taught us this game mustache tv
mustache tv yeah has anybody played that
before no look see people know basically
what you do is you take a mustache you
can make one yourself you can draw it on
which is not good if you're at a hotel
and then you stick it on the tv and you
and you pray like you're at a sporting
event that somebody will walk directly
into the market
that a character will just walk into the
mustache yes and and it feels like you
won or you did something really great
can you show us how this works
i'm gonna i'm gonna put it i'm gonna put
it on our yeah i'm gonna put it on there
okay and then i'm gonna get some for all
of us okay and you just go over to that
monitor where i look sickly come back
okay i'm just going to pick random
places this is not staged and then yeah
is that going to ruin our tv because
that's the only one we can afford well
you might have to get in yes we got to
take care of that tv so you can just
stick these to your television
yeah i mean be careful if it's not your
own television i would be careful
okay here we go this is gonna oh no
that's that's maybe a little ambitious
well okay let's see you could probably
paint it in nail polish too something
like that okay okay
this is gonna be challenging all right
can you see that monitor on tv you can
see it
okay all right you see it well there's
one down here that's like
just like
test
[Applause]
it's like i had a brazilian you know
what the hell is that all about so i
have to be down here and you have to be
you've got to take this one here oh oh
that's hard oh wait a minute hold it oh
this is primitive
[Applause]
andy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for us that's really saying something i
want to ask you about a picture that i
saw that confused me uh you were on the
set of parks and recreation and uh
you're with your co-star amy poehler and
something's going on maybe you can tell
us what's happening here there's a lot
of hugging and then your leg starts to
wrap around
amy poehler and uh curious what's going
on here when i hug someone
my legs like instinctively wrap around
them
really yeah when you hug somebody your
leg really does
yeah not everyone but it's something
that's happened since i was a child my
grandfather used to call me like monkey
and for every christmas he gives me a
stuffed monkey
and he's like you're a monkey you always
wrap your legs
around it's just like a monkey
reflex
ron swanson the character famously uh
part of his character was he's a meat
lover and believed in meat and the and
the power of just meat eating that's
right when that did that ever get you
special treatment in a restaurant say oh
sure yeah no uh for years um even to
this day when i'm in a restaurant i will
often you know you know you weigh the
way people will send you over a drink in
a bar yeah people send me over a
porterhouse
[Laughter]
from the uh
then you have to hold it up right yeah
thank you
from the gentleman with the
face
did this how was this for your health
was your doctor okay with all this it
was great for my mood um
and my pelt yeah
uh was shiny but
eventually
eventually my doctor said uh
your um your artery walls are very thick
and that's
not great no it's not supposed to be
great no we want to thin them so um so i
cut it you know i cut down to like 87
red meat diet
that's an inspiration to a lot of people
watching right now you can do it if you
can get down to 87
red meat you are a proud
proud american